[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est la nouvelle idée d' emmanuel
macron pour aider le continent africain
après avoir reçu les dirigeants
africains à paris en est déjà formulé
des inquiétudes quant à la lutte contre
l'occident en afrique
début juin à quelques jours des sommets
du g7 et de l'otan le président français
a exhorté le fmi à vendre une partie de
ses réserves d'or pour leur venir en
aide
l'idée serait en fait de financer un new
deal un grand plan de sauvetage à
hauteur de 100 milliards de dollars
car pour le moment les aides allouées
par le fmi à l'afrique ont été minimes
et s'élever à à peine 37 milliards de
dollars
avec également un gel de la tène dans
ces pays l'or valeur refuge par
excellence pourrait donc aider l'afrique
à se relever
le fmi détient 2008 114 tonnes d'or soit
192 milliards de dollars juste derrière
les états unis et l'allemagne en france
se sont donné 4 136 tonnes d'or qui
était conservée par la banque de france
à la fin de l'année 2020 un peu plus de
120 milliards d'euros
reste à savoir si c'est le bon moment
pour vendre de l'or et si justement dans
un moment de crise et avec autant
d'argent qui circule sur les marchés en
ce moment il ne serait pas plus malins
même pour le fmi de garder ses réserves
de métal jaune